antenne 2 et philips vous présente le
bar de la plage
l'émission d'été de thierry ardisson
[Musique]
le vieux piano de la place de jeux
console quand solitude vieux pianos de
la plage à des clients dont l'habitude
de danser le samedi le dimanche
les autres jours ça sur les planches
dans la mer il se souvient il rêve son
fait mais c'est alors le sang tout court
battu de ma cachette et que soudain de
rang tremblante et mis en lui charrette
c'est inouï tout ce que je retour comme
cette musique joli mais proulx me fait
du mal
me fait du bien non c'est trop adieu
adieu piano bonsoir bienvenue au bar de
la plage avec relax max à l'aise blaise
tu parles charles
comment faire pour ne rien faire quand
on a rien à faire un expert explique il
a encore rêvé d'elle elle sa fille
joëlle notre leçon hebdomadaire de
philosophie locale la plage à la page
andré bercoff ivres de livres les
aventures de lolo chez les blaireaux du
bord de l'eau très chaud pour les petits
marie le bradshaw de marie et le barman
qui ne jouera qu'à bon escient
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
tout le monde se rue urbain
le film
[Musique]
watchmen
toi même
jamais
[Musique]
ouais
et
par trois fois
je suis amer
[Musique]
oh
m
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
ce soir denis un simple machine fixe
répondu en tapant 36 tesco déroule à la
question suivante quel est le surnom des
charbonniers du coup pris les petits
pois
[Musique]
bonsoir jacqueline j'ai confiance en
vous monsieur vous voulez jacky que vous
me prêtez l'oreille monsieur jacques pas
de vous écouter jacky parfaitement
chanter je suis je ne sais rien de vous
voir les magiciens des magiciens qui n'y
arrivent bien rester barman jacky ça ne
marchera jamais
charles quel est pour vous le premier
lieu associés aux vacances berck plage
ces housses à berck plage cet acte est à
côté de moi merlimont plage c'est tout
en haut de sur normandie
alors moi j'avais les jambes arquées et
à l'époque quand on avait des
déficiences dans les eaux on envoyait
les enfants à berck plage pour le
donneur pour le pour le bonheur et ça
m'a remis les gens de droite la tête
points mais les lambris vous ai des
souvenirs de bande de copains de grosses
bêtises avec les copains à berck non à
merlimont non plus n'ont pas tellement
j'ai toujours été un enfant un petit peu
sérieux comme on a eu un passé assez
haché difficile alors on est con et et
les enfants sérieux qu on nous disait
toujours fait attention pourquoi se
faire remarquer on a été bien reçue dans
ce pays tenez vous bien s'étirer
l'instant je te met bien en se tenant
bien manger pour leur chose vous ai des
souvenirs d'amours de vacances petite
fille sur la place comme ça à berck ou à
garder mon même rame directement chez le
traiteur votre premier baiser c'est à
quel âge
en 12 ans à 12 ans 12 ans web et aider
des chansons de cette époque qui vous
ont marqués en voleurs y en a plein
c'est quoi par exemple les gars de la
marine marine elle s'est pas légale la
marine joue les pères de la fin quand on
est dans l'épaule je dirais que marine
est là bas quand j'ai pression
certificat d'études en ma vie du film
demandé de chanter une chanson il chante
et marie-aude na waie et on m'a dit
quand vous appelez jeudi à genève orient
et les moyens à l'époque au mans il ya
d'argent témoin la marseillaise ont
pensé que je connaissais pas la
marseillaise j'ai réussi à en sortir
quelques couplets qu'on a pas mal oui
parce qu'ils avaient peu de français qui
ne le savaient et l'adolescent c'était
quoi vos vacances aux vacances de
rétention pour pas bon parce qu'on
n'avait pas les moyens
je crois que les premières vacances qui
sont tes premières vacances on les a eus
à 13 ans j'ai encore une photo de mes
parents et d'un groupe
d'arméniens dans l'eau jusqu'à la
ceinture et le poing levé parce que
c'était le front populaire et que
c'étaient les premières vacances payées
vous avez déjà des 500 dans la tête à
cette époque oui j'avais déjà écrit une
chanson avec ma soeur elle avait fait la
musique j'avais fait les paroles
j'avais première chanson j'ai écrites
quand j'avais 7 8 ans c'est une histoire
d'une voiture amphibie qui parle qui
allait sur l'eau et sur la terre je me
souviens plus très bien mais ma fille ma
soeur s'en souvient alors des fois le
même mal rappelle aujourd'hui vos
vacances c'est quoi c'est un drop et
saint tropez uniquement uniquement j'ai
fait le tour du monde plusieurs fois
j'ai vu les plus beaux coins du monde
bon je me suis arrêté à acapulco chez
raven qui en thaïlande un peu partout
que la floride la californie le plus
beaux coins du monde c'est d'abord sur
la méditerranée bon c'est pas si la
corse bien sûr mais moi je me sens plus
à l'aise ici ça me permet de voyager
d'aller encore survenir
et là vous avez acheté une maison à
saint tropez mais vous trouvez pas de la
région est un peu galvaudé quand même
donc la région est très très construit
très batik un peu frelaté l'été sans
trembler comme avare de boire le verre
est très bien d'autre part saint tropez
c'est l'auberge espagnole vous voulez
vous éclatez vous éclater voulait rester
au calme ou rester au calme voulait leur
un coin particulier vous pouvez y aller
on fait ce que vous voulez à saint
tropez les gens qui viennent me dire on
va pas à s'introduire s'il ya trop de
monde ça n'est pas vrai il ya du monde
sur le port vient de visiter puis repart
si vous voulez vivre normalement vous
pourrez vivre en famille tout à fait
normalement mais vous qu'est ce qu'est
la première chose que vous faites quand
vous arrivez en vacances prochains jours
d'abord je n'arrête pas de travailler
pendant huit jours bougeait pas il
les choses à faire dans une maison qu'on
n'a pas abandonné pendant un an donc je
fais toujours plein de choses il faut
tout revoir tout refaire et mes vacances
commencent lorsque tout est terminé
alors au bout de huit jours qu'est ce
que vous faites après en vacances je
fais pas grand chose le matin j'ai créé
un petit peu et puis je descends sur le
sur le port pense qu'il ya pas beaucoup
de monde le matin là je prends mon
journal je vais au bistrot je rencontre
les journalistes habituellement ils sont
tous là on peut faire une photo je dis
non d'ailleurs régulièrement réservé
beaucoup en vacances des journalistes et
il me fiche la paix ouais on se connaît
depuis très longtemps et le côté
paparazzi ça n'existe plus surtout si on
n'a pas tellement exister en france mais
c'est vrai alors ses horaires comme ça
très très sérieux de déjeuner à 2h de
vous coucher tout vous coucher vers
quelle heure le soir des jeunes habillés
mais ouais je me couche vers 10h30
ah ouais avec un bouquin ménage au book
in jusqu'à minuit à bout à bout alors
j'ai des choses à apprendre à mémoriser
je le fais le soir dans mon livre c'est
là qu'on apprend le mieux ne vous sentez
pas dans les boîtes dont j'ai eu mon
temps ouais qu'est ce que vous faites
quand vous faites rien alors dans la
journée ah non moi je ne m'arrive pas
d'orienter à bord dont j'ai toujours
quelque chose
par exemple je sais pas moi ya toujours
un truc à réparer à bruz tard voir
quelqu'un a rencontré quelque chose à
écrire un coup de téléphone à donner non
non j'ai toujours quelque chose à faire
faites du sport en vacances n'ont pas de
sport non bonjour bull n'ont jamais au
casino non non je suis pas joueur disait
pas où est annoncé alors pour un
oriental pan du tout faites des siestes
n'ont jamais n'ont même pas des siestes
crapuleuses
parce que l'été c'est la grande
spécialité quand on vous regarde
quel est votre meilleur accessoire de
repos l'été le sable le livre le hamac
n'y en a pas rien pas il au niveau vous
devez pas vous allonger sur la plage
naturelle produite
je ne me mets pas au soleil ouais je vis
au soleil
parce que finalement ce qu'il faut c'est
profiter du soleil mais se mettre au
soleil il y en a même qui ont un truc en
main sur le coup comme ça des fois du
soleil que dans la figure et puis à la
fin de leur vie ils ont des tâches dans
tous les sens je vous fait pas ses
avocats ont regardé pas d'opération il
est parfait parfait je sais pas mais
bercy 6 très en forme et votre femme
elle va bien merci
[Musique]
le jour parfait
vous parlez français jamais vu un aussi
bel homme vous avez un corps de rêve
voulait absolument voulu dire ce matin
je me mélange les vrais buteurs chez
thomson jours c'est pour moi un travail
parce qu'elles sont et je deviens moi là
je suis très fort c'est vrai aux
chanceux très fraîche c'est un petit
bonhomme mais qui auront comment l'art
au squat j'arrive à faire deux cents
kilos quand même une fois je pense que
sa boutique ils ont essayé de
m'entraîner mais c'est pas comme bourg
c'est vrai que c'est au premier abord
constat que là bas c'est vrai tu m'avais
repéré de la voie à la barre
j'existe et surtout faire un peu de
parisiens chantonne 19 fring avec moi a
bondi déjà l'ouverture sera ma part je
suis très très jalouse cette équipe de
57 ans qui viendra qui va voir que la
zone sont très gentils je sais pas si tu
vois les missions de foucault ou est
elle bien cette année la bague dorée à
terre là comment s'appelle laurence
aouita des belles filles alors sera la
compétition là je viens de la connaître
seulement parce qu'elle m'a vraiment
observer je suis pas pour moi j'ai rien
du tout alors qu'ils ne regardent
trempée
je vois toujours auprès des banques
qu'est ce qu'elle veut elle est très
gentil mais pas méchant alors blizzard a
notamment des copains du natus attitude
intéresse la parole ils ont cependant
vous avez vu le doublement délais parce
qu'elle soit ne peut pas manger les gens
se trompent pas donc les gens qui se
dégage dégage d'une fuite d'acide dans
l'eau parce que je pourrais y dans tous
les fait toutes craquer moi je ne bouge
pas c'est pas c'est pas mon genre je
voulais voir partout j'étais en sicile
tu as la cote c'est pour ça que j'étais
dépité vite parce que les gens le
regardent
j'aime même patienter un petit peu ça
suffit après qu'on me foute la paix
qu'il a su parce que je pourrais venir
dormir chez toi tu veux bah ouais il ya
trois d'appeler et s'entourer dans tes
bras et ça ça doit être un réel
changement mais moi je vous dit rien
parce qu'il semble chirurgie pas de
bruit pas se poser les bons jeux mac os
x
oui mais s'ils entendent des petits cris
ils vont se poser des questions moi
j'aime bien cris mettra la main sur la
bouche je risque ne m'excite beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup
reportage
la première fois que jean henry se fait
à peine un quart d'heure qu'on se
connaît depuis déjà que tu m'aimes
[Musique]
puis je vous connais et moi je trouve
barman jacquet ce n'est pas parce que
l'on trouve que l'on connaît monsieur
c'est connu et vous regarder la télé en
travaillant c'est lors de mes cours
particuliers en dessous vous apprenez
quoi nourrir les poissons
ce ne sont pas les mots qui compte
monsieur que le rituel
[Musique]
- bruno quand tu vois la méditerranée la
turquie est pas d'avoir passé les
vacances de son enfance au cap gris nez
non non je suis un fils du nord et fier
de l'être et dont c'était la mère était
moins bleu mais savait sans charme les
grandes falaises on voyait envoyer
l'angleterre quand il faisait beau ce
qui est arrivé de temps en temps et
après la costa brava sata pas plus et
tout où j'avais dix ans de plus donc
j'étais un petit peu moins sage c'est
avec les cousins cousines c'est toute
chose hein tu veux m'en parler à l'herbe
et j'espère bien tu vas me dire par
exemple son premier amour de vacances
c'était quand c'était en 68 mais c'était
pas vraiment comment des vacances
j'étais juste avant juste avant les
vacances je vais la première expérience
sexuelle le seul comment allait bien
alors bruno je connais tous les deux là
que nous deux y a plus que nous et la
mère et la mère va me parler d amour de
vacances alors oui c'était comment j'ai
pas de souvenirs plus plus fort que
pendant le lennon vacances main est
arrivé de faire des galipettes sur des
plages de me faire surprendre par les
les flics ou les gendarmes
mais bon on est un peu sous toutes les
latitudes mais je suis pas programmé
pour faire l'amour le super maman je dis
ou s'il n'est pas plus l'amour en
vacances que pendant l'année toi non
plus tôt - ah bon ce qui va changer
c'est fait pour se reposer même de sa
wii dis-moi tu as dit j'ai été puceau
très tard c'est à dire ça veut dire quoi
ça le là le vrai rapport sexuel c'est
pas vers 22 ans n'ont été saisis a
grimpé de puymoyen 16 euros
des gentillesses mais non mais c'était à
l'époque faut se rappeler que y'avait
pas vraiment la contraception
moi je me souviens la première fille
avec qui j'ai fait l'amour c'est j'étais
enfin que passer mon temps pour m'en dtp
à calculer si on s'était pas gouré dnat
donc c'était
c'était moins évident quoi c'était
l'époque de la méthode ogino passé
compliqué alors dix mois après tu as
fait beaucoup de voyages a pressé ses
vacances au cap gris nez c'est ses
vacances sur la costa brava qui a fait
beaucoup de voyages et quels sont les
endroits qui ont le plus marqués quelles
sont les cartes postales que tu tues
garde en mémoire
bon ma femme travailler dans une
compagnie aérienne donc regarder chuté à
coquelles paix maintenant ll travail
france d'une tombée bien bas
elle travaille dans une société de
production de télévision oulala qu'elle
fasse attention et donc c'était pascal
grecque parce qu'on regardait la
mappemonde en disant on pouvait vraiment
aller partout en plus on avait des
billets d'avion à 10% donc ce n'était
pas vraiment un problème
et finalement après avoir hésité pendant
trois semaines entre los angeles tahiti
et bora bora où on allait dans le lot en
train ouï dire ça me coûtait plus cher
le billet d'avion pour aller du moins
alors justement tes vacances aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que tu fais maintenant que tu
as épuisé toutes les joies de ne pas
épuiser mais c'est vrai que pour avoir
beaucoup beaucoup bourlingué aux quatre
fois et c'est génial vraiment sans
chauvinisme je trouve que la france et
les français se rendent pas assez court
et le plus beau pays est tout à fait
clair donc je moi j'aime bien aller en
france j'aime bien les dents dans ce
qu'on appelle la france profonde
le massif central parce que c'est
vraiment authentique ya pas trop de
touristes et de ça ils ont en fait je
squatte chez des copains ouais et et ont
bu vraiment on bulle on est bien entre
nous bookeen on déconne on people on va
au restaurant c'est chez nous et cela
c'est chez des copains que ces squats
dans le lot là c'est ça ça se passe
comment alors une journée là bas passe
rien justement c'est ça qui forme et on
s'ennuie pas une minute mais ya pas de
piscine c'est vraiment une maison tout
aille à la piscine il ya une espèce de
piscines en plein cyber base pour
tromper parce que quelquefois il fait
sourire mais non bookeen on est vraiment
bien chacun vit sa vie
c'est bien parce que justement il se
passe rien ça fait des années qu'on se
voyait jamais on s'est engueulés jamais
tiens tu fais rien rien rien bilbo
couvert en plus comme on connaît un peu
le coin parce qu'on a bien sonné on n'a
même plus la curiosité d'aller vers les
sites touristiques en plus y'a du monde
en duo
donc on reste chez nous tranquilles ou
alors on va aller vous à voir les
voisins enfin c'est vraiment une vie de
village
tu crois que c'est un art de savoir rien
faire comme ça oui c'est difficile en
plus je ne sais pour l'expérimenté
points
j'ai beaucoup travaillé la question et
c'est vrai que bull et
c'est quoi but les bulles et c'est
justement ne n'avoir aucune obligation
rien sur son agenda aucun rendez-vous
qu'un coup de fil à passer et puis
pouvoir se dire je me fais cap cinéma de
suisse
je reste au lit tout seul ou accompagné
toute la journée je vais faire du sport
je fais mon jardin enfin c'est de
n'avoir aucun plan de travail
là tu es un spécialiste moi j'aimais
bien mais c'est vrai alors l'oise yves
tétant la maire de toul et c'est bien là
pour une fois ça ça dérape s'apprête à
des occupations qui sont alors tu écris
un bocal en ce moment c'est sur soi sur
le mensonge
ah bon alors je souffre beaucoup parce
que avant de laisser libre cours à mon
délire dont je gémis cryptée en écrivant
la suisse est plus contraignant comme
écriture
donc c
moins jouissif mais parce que c'est un
truc construit et que pas sérieux je
suis incapable de faire un bouquin c'est
pour moi je crois que non mais on croit
qu'on peut dire des choses extrêmement
important grave en déconnant quoi donc
mais c'est un vrai boulot est ce qui
t'arrive de dire des mensonges quand il
présente le journal
oh bah oui pas volontairement non mais
c'est vrai que quand on annonce la mort
de quelqu'un même si c'est quelqu'un
pour qui on n'a pas de l'indifférence ou
même de l'hostilité on va pas l'annoncer
avec un grand sourire dont il ya une
part de comédie
forcément on prend une tête
d'enterrement quand on annonce le décès
de quelqu'un même si c'est un mec mais
c'est quelqu'un pour qui on n'a aucune
estime il était arrivé de lancer des
fausses nouvelles toi sur le wii / petit
mission enragé sur la roumanie j'étais
de services donc j'ai déconné autant que
les autres et mais même dans journal bon
je soutiens donc sur la marée noire qui
était un petit aspect de la guerre
on a tous dit on a tous dit comme en
écho en disant que c'était la marée
noire du siècle d'or qui s'est avéré un
an après que c'est même un pas à pas
grand chose
et quand les journalistes interview est
ce qui t'arrive de dire des mensonges
non c'est pas des mensonges ses
dimensions par omission sur qui a des
choses moi je suis le porte parole d'une
action donc il ya des choses que je ne
peux pas dire oui je ne peux pas dire
sur ma vie privée
qu'est ce tu vas faire là ce soir après
l'émission je te pose des questions
l'outil va sortir sortir nombre à guy
peut-être à il sort pas beaucoup dans
les boîtes son gérant de saab ce que
j'aime pas le bruit et point d'oreille
donc c'est vite et puis j'aime j'ai
horreur de la fumée donc je vis pas bien
mais en ayant pour les bois non pas
d'une étude ragoût alors je ne sais pas
vers le banc peut-être au bar de la
place à repérer déjà un peu non
[Musique]
les sous
oui
[Musique]
nous
je
prix
ah bon
[Musique]
l'amour
b
oui
odile
[Musique]
chez nous
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
je suis
[Musique]
tout cela
oui
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
vous ne parlez jamais d'amour g qui pour
quoi faire parler de nous à monsieur
temps n'est pas plus mais au moins ça se
trouve alors parlons un peu de sexe ne
parlerai pas de mon sexe monsieur c'est
une trop longue histoire
[Musique]
sales usa puis ça va alors tu habites ou
aya au lavandou la banlieue ouest saint
clair pourquoi là pour savoir baba assez
bon ces mots qu'est ce t'as fait dans sa
vie même pas d'autres mots ce quatier
avait bousculé dans un basket c'est un
autre quartier c'est quelqu'un si
quelqu'un qui allait donner dans la
forêt et qui coupait tout le dessous
dans lé cas le droit de s'en remettre à
le voir le coupé des arbres et avec ça
ce n'est pas ici ouais c'est à dire les
piscines c'était départ aux copains aux
boulangers qui faisait cuire le pays à
bon on commence à haut débit il y avait
moins de feu à l'époque c'était et après
on faisait des souches de graulhet pour
le type alors que les pies possible
d'apprendre sopra away voyons ça c'est
bon sachant combien est suivi de quoi là
maintenant wesley lautoa tôt à bord la
retraite de quoi les barons cela te des
travailleurs la retraite ça te fait
combien par mois à 53,8 à 800 francs par
mois comment tu fais et quand je me
débrouille quand tu fais quoi de tes
journées là maintenant je regarde
l'avenir
ah bon et oui tu peux rester combien de
temps à regarder la mer 3 4h ou 5h moi
je passe je me mets sur un rocher je
regarde c'est un état je vois pas c'est
un guerrier un oiseau n'importe quoi et
c'est beau de montréal est la première
fois dans le tiercé à achat d'or donc
avec des licences dont dépendent les
moyens à jouer à la baballe à bord du
ferry gagne deux tiers de la chambre et
j'ai trouvé même mieux ouais et chercher
des champignons
je sais pas trop les chercher moi il
faut qu'il soit vu comme une banale que
ce soir à la tour eiffel en fait j'ai
tapé dedans je suis je suis bio pour
toujours at on aussi je me lève l omnium
voit plus rien et c'est quoi une banane
le panache d'un grand secours b1 et tu
ramasses quoi comme champignons quand tu
les trouves c'est bon et surprenant
la grolle promener ou pour les trouver
mais ou dans les vallons à la mort tu
vas à la chasse pourquoi ne pas tuer les
animaux n'ont acquis aux oiseaux aux
pies dans les jardins après autour et au
moins d'eau et puis soudain un gardien
sur le gardien c'est le goût et la viola
ils sont tellement habitués les matières
de base aux carriers j'ai pas une égérie
maintenant je crois et les femmes alors
qu'andrew des troupes d'avancer peu plus
dur avec là encore il doit plus bandé et
en fait c'est pas vrai qu'à venir on est
tous les deux aujourd'hui répondre non
pas de prendre des pilules
ouais vous départir tu as eu combien de
femmes dans sa vie
oui pour nous je n'arrive plus à les
copier ouais ouais je me souviens lui le
marié whitacre art et marié troillet du
mali pana
penneteau nova j'aime beaucoup le cas de
la pio voilà c'est tout si vous lui au
bord de la mer
quand il ya un village a perdu deux
dents tu as beaucoup durant sa vie cela
du pastaga ouais pourquoi d'abord à ses
talents qui ton môme il n'y a pas de
grosses des gros appareil et il vient ni
barbe ni les dd chaude et noir s'est
noyé nos petits tant que ça car on
carbure bimota pas debout
le mahb eu combien de litres dans ta vie
un peu vrai y seriez jamais fait
peut-être de minuit de 2008 c'est quoi
un demi oui c'est une grosse barre et
que 250 euros pour sa demi ton peut-être
plus je le sais rien cit avait un
conseil à donner aux gens
ils nous regardent ce mardi avec moi et
bien qu'ils soient qu'ils soient heureux
je trouve que les gens aujourd'hui
savent plus être heureux peut-être pas
des fois je rentre dans des boîtes
journée jeunes yankees en cela l autre
qui donne cela je dirai tout dégât
galles selon la députée c'est comme ça
avant que tu donnes si tu prenais la
goom radio offert si on fait une tango
swing tango
il devrait danser le slow plus là sur
bar une posture il aurait fait sentir ce
qui a incité à donetsk est ce que tu
fais oui tu te bats or le pouvoir là
haut
et vous savez que c'est ça il me semble
que tu as raison mais je pense tu crois
que tu es un philosophe s'applique
j'espérais que ça veut dire
[Musique]
fédou ce soir qui ça monsieur personne
tu disais il fait vous vous n'avez
jamais essayé de mettre un nom sur ce il
obsédant monsieur il neige une vente
il va pleuvoir il fait beau comme et evo
jacky ce n'est qu'une histoire de
grammaire française
non monsieur le dernier le plus
pernicieux ce il était une fois il
commence toujours les histoires mais
seulement quand tout est fini
rêver dès la semaine
elle n'a rien fait
[Musique]
il n'est pas vraiment belle
c'est mieux elle est faite pour moi
[Musique]
doucet
j'ai pour mon cas
je les ai rêvé si fort
que l'état s'en souviennent
e
je te remets dans son camp
bercé par c'est le thème
si je
[Musique]
à c
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
à
et ce quoi
on est témoin
ce soir
une nuit juste où elle est
et demain
m
[Musique]
géant
rêvé d'elle
pour ça
[Musique]
pas vraiment belle mois
je
si je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
soit
une nuit
juste way
[Musique]
je
et
[Musique]
moi
m
je ne
tout cela
echard de weeds bonsoir alors que le riz
ton du groupe
il était une fois mais pourquoi gritton
parce que quand on s'appelle richard
c'est que ça voilà quinze ans qu'on va
pas appeler rythme ça fait 15 ans qu'on
n'a pas vérifié par la région le sais je
sais tout règles tu le batteur il était
une fois j'ai tel souhaité le batteur
oui
dans cette chanson est sortie en quelle
année angers info révélait 75 75
et comment s'est passée la création de
cette chanson elle s'est passé très
rapidement
c'est une des musiques que j'ai mis le
moins de temps à composer
j'ai dû mettre une heure ou telle chose
comme ça et puis le texte est venu aussi
très vite et serge pollen qui fait
qu'ils aient tous les textes sur un coin
de table boom krak tu viens dans quelles
circonstances il a écrite la musique
je me souviens de l'endroit où je les
fait ouais c'est vrai à l'époque j'avais
été un petit studio à courbevoie et dans
le placard à balais j'avais aménagé un
petit studio d'enregistrement en cours
entre des cartons à eux ça et je
décompose et la nuit comme certaine sa
c'est tombé du ciel voix mais tu savais
en l'écrivant tu avais le sentiment que
tu avais fait un truc bien où c'était
une chanson de plus noir là c'était trop
lyrique et en plus quand l'album est
sorti avec cette chanson dans le tas la
maison de disques et nous mêmes on
pensait que c'était
c'était pas un tube personne n'y avait
pas de refrain s'était pas pu être poète
s'était trop lyrique personne n'y
croyait en fait effectivement alors
l'album est sorti comme ça avec une
autre chanson en promotion 0,1 sur
l'album et c'est les médias qui nous ont
mais vous êtes fous là vous avez une
chanson tu dis pas plus fin que voilà et
puis on a recommencé la promotion sur
j'ai encore rêvé d'elle et c'est vrai
qu'entre vous l'appeliez j'ai encore des
brèdes suel ouais ouais
alors il y avait un cas social c'est
perrine qu'un steak way vient faire un
tour sous l'ampli au lieu de venir à
tours sur les prix c'est le cas de le
dire cela alors il était une fois
c'était cinq garçons cinq garçons et une
fille mais d'abord les cinq garçons
c'était quoi vous juillet que polnareff
c'est ça non cr serge qui était le
parolier du groupe
lui et moi on est des amis d'enfance
c'est connu à l'âge de 5 ans qu'on a on
a commencé à faire de la musique à l'âge
de 15 ans environ dans les premiers
groupes on s'est appelé tour à tour les
people et les pays de l est les français
des étudiants les beatles aux accros du
beatles
je sais à quelle époque je veux défriser
les cheveux je mettais des bacs pour
rassembler ringo et ensuite on a changé
le nom d'affilée rythme and blues dans
ces appelés les jelly roll
ce qu'on a toujours été ensemble tous
les deux on a accompagné un tas de gens
on l'a été avec trenet avec henri
salvador avec polnareff pendant deux ans
et demi et puis parallèlement à ça on a
fait plein de groupes qui ont changé de
nom très souvent et puis un jour on a
décidé de faire un dernier groupe
on avait arrêté polnareff parce qu'il
était malade et puis on s'est dit bon on
verra bien quoi pas resté les routes de
la dernière chance
j'en avais un peu
et joël comment vous l'avez rencontrée
alors joël c'était à l'époque où serge
et moi on accompagnait polnareff dont
michel donner un gala à port grimaud ce
jour là il nous avait prêté sa mustang
blanche décapotable et on était parti
faire une en vadrouille sur le port de
saint-tropez
et puis à la terrasse du gorille parmi
les clients qui avaient joël et sa soeur
qui était là j'étais tout jeune tous les
deux et puis bon voilà c'est ça et puis
et puis serge et joël donc re sympathisé
plus que voilà jusqu'où ils sont prêts
et voilà la elvis a commencé ici alors
comment s'est terminée tout ça un jour
c'est vrai que c'est la rupture entre
entre serge et joël qui a commencé c'est
pas vraiment ça sert qu'on était honteux
qu'on tournait énormément on avait en
moyenne dans à partir de 75 française
jusqu'à la fin
genre 200 gala part en tournée sur
tournée on rentrait à paris on avait
juste le temps de faire des photos des
td de composer de nouvelles chansons et
on était 24 heures sur 24 ensemble et
puis on était quelques uns en groupe à
avoir envie de faire autre chose un
petit peu ce se prendre une année
sabbatique quoi bon le manque
d'intelligence de certains quoi je pense
qu'il faut voir plus loin moi j'aurais
bien aimé qu'on soit les compagnons de
la chanson que dans 19 en 2020 en soit
encore la fin j'ai un peu mais et puis
c'était plus possible il y avait trop de
dissensions entre nous et il y en avait
qui a failli faire du rock'n'roll
l'odcav envie de chanter seul essai un
peu compréhensible et un moment c'est
tous partis vers des vers des carrières
solo c'est ça absolument aussi bah oui
moi depuis 80 j'ai fait tout de suite un
album qui est sorti qu'il comme on dit a
succédé stream qui a bien marché au
québec
enfin en france ça n'a pas été le pied
en quelle année ça s'est arrêté il était
une fois fin 79
voilà donc quand joël est morte en 82 16
et 3 ans et est actuellement
ça fait dix ans qu'elle est mort d'un
arrêt cardiaque ouais due à une overdose
est ce que est ce que toi tu
tu savais ça tu savais quelque des
français non non non parce que à
l'époque avec vous je n'avais jamais eu
ce sentiment non bon les pétards des
trucs comme ça mais bon sincèrement je
savais pas et puis pendant ce des trois
ans avant sa mort moi je roule à des
traits plus de rapports on se téléphone
être très peu c'est dommage d'ailleurs
on regrette toujours après l'été au
compteur après ça j'étais chez moi et
c'est je peux citer c'était européen qui
m'a appelé un matin en me disant écoutez
voilà on a une information faucon là
faut qu'on nous l'a confirmé
si on vous appelle vers 13 heures
pendant europe deux europes midi pardon
c'est que la nouvelle est confirmée et
malheureusement il m'explique le truc je
suis tombé par terre ça fait c'est un
choc terrible là et ils m'ont rappelé
malheureusement 13 heures ça fait très
très très bizarre
est-ce que tu as souffert de ce
changement de situation austère de
passer d'une star études absolument
total 1 espèce d'un anonyme améliorée au
tout début oui parce qu'on s'imagine pas
quand on a systématiquement un disque
qui sort et on s'est systématiquement on
sera dans tous les domaines dont on
prend des mauvaises habitudes entier
attend je comprends pas la géniale on va
faire un album
on a mis dans ces données un mal fou
j'ai déjà vu c'était des belles chansons
dont je ne comprenais pas que ce soit le
flop et au fil de talent et je suis
habitué je me suis débrouillé j'ai fait
d'autres choses
j'ai fait des chansons pour enfants des
disques des les indicatifs pour la télé
et que oui vraiment parce que je
diversifie mes activités je fais un tas
de choses est ce que tu crois que il
était une fois aurait pu être un grand
groupe
où ça a été un grand oui absolument être
un très grand groupe si on avait gardé
le même état d'esprit que dans les cinq
premières années oui absolument
avec la chose ah oui il y avait une
magie un truc on se comprenait tout de
suite en arrivant au studio je sais pas
enfin si mais on avait la foi
déjà ce pourrait s'appeler dutil fois
mais bon j'avais un feeling huawei vite
ça s'est un peu dégradée bon tu
regrettes ah bah oui c'est sûr laissez
passer à côté d'un truc énorme
non c'est même pas ça c'est que c'est ma
plus belle aventure de musiciens s'est
il était une fois de plus pas musicien
ça fait un paquet d'années que je fais
ça c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
d'assez l'âge de 46 ans ces papiers
disons cruellement mais disons d'avoir
ton avenir derrière toi non non non
parce que c'est des choses que j'ai
faites
je n'ai pas derrière moi avec moi
toujours c'est pour finir je suis pas
encore gâteau je pense cavalaire alors
dit moi j'ai un album qui sort
législateur voilà alors on va parler de
2,10 d'abord une compile de il était une
fois qui s'appelle comment je me sens
génial appelle les plus belles fois
c'est joli c'est bien trouvé ça c'est
une idée de xsigo de imai nous on les a
mais tout au long de sa vie sur le fed a
compris très bonne surprise puisque on
pensait pas que ça marche très très bien
ça fait 2 fois disque d'or étonnant hein
c'est étonnant et un album alors alors
mon album moi j'ai mis une bonne année
et demi enregistré parce qu'on ne veut
pas faire n'importe quoi avec un
producteur indépendant
ça va sortir on a retardé un peu la
sortie à cros d'il était une fois il
s'en sortir en octobre
et puis on verra bien quoi je veux dire
si ça marche tant mieux
et si ça marche pas ton frère et puis
alors c'est une profession de foi
moi je veux dire c'est s'est massé ma
passion c'est ma vie et je peux pas
vivre sans bon musicaux complètement
mais y'a pas de honte à ça alors
[Musique]
vous avez mordu la ligne blanche vous
avez vu non parce que c'est mal foutu on
est obligé de la mordre au carrefour qui
allait les trucs de pierre-alain qui
bloque
oui on s'était installé le truc je sais
comment ça marche bonjour m beau temps
et il avait mordu la ligne blanche
je regarde mon dieu c'est mal foutu mais
ils foncent à des difficultés pour
baiser les gens quoi parce que là où
vous savez ce que vous perdez la seule
permis c'est combien de points dit le
sait pas cadets 2 points pour ça
aujourd'hui madame sur si ça va vite ça
les piles à comme ils vous ont repéré au
top au talkie walkie
moi je suis obligé de vous mettre la
mode c'est dégueulasse le même mois en
tant que conducteur ça me choque et je
suis obligé de le faire parce que vous
faites ça ou ces trois jours à la plage
n'avait plus de permis malin est-ce que
vous avez la ceinture on a des paillis
vous êtes prudente résister puis vous
perdez deux points quand même défaut de
présentation des papiers
excusez-moi temps pour moi je n'essaie
pas de point ses trois points que vous
tournez trois points mais si je fais le
tour de la voiture de tête on retrouve
un quatrième de points je ne peux pas
être facile vous avez de l'argent vous
comment voulez vous arranger ça sans
arroser les flics
[Musique]
c'est ce que vous allez pas vous allez
aller chez vous et vous allez prendre
205 en liquide parce qu'il faut arroser
tout le cas d'accord on va faire la
distrib ça va faire cinq ans à que
chacun moi je prends rien sur vous parce
que vous mettez en pratique est comme ça
ils vont laisser tomber d'accord
d'accord
prenez pas des billets marqué un des
numéros qui suivent parce que ça les
énerve
voilà prenez des billets sur des choses
comme ça et puis ramenée à +2 pinard
aussi des trois bouteilles de rosé c'est
comme ça on fonctionne comme ça et là on
est en démocratie enflé curan laragné du
vin quand même et puis pile journal
éventuellement et pour moi vous me
prenez deux cartouches de marlboro
simplement
ou alors c'est ce qu'on va faire moi je
vais arroser le collègue donc donné 200
francs de la main à la main chaude en
cinq ans et puis je fais 100 francs pour
moi était comme ça c'est bon 17
non merci ça va pour cette fois ci la
prochaine fois vous pour les 400 francs
parce qu'il y aura les collègues
la prévision
je me repositionner non c'est pas grave
comme ça nous ça nous fera des ronds
pour picoler tout c'est bon pour nous je
vous assure
[Musique]
regardez toute cette eau jacky c'est
reposant non non plus beau monsieur je
vous ferai capable d'être bucolique
jacky vous me décevez l'onuci monsieur
est la meilleure preuve c'est qu'elle
trouve le même lac saint jean
[Musique]
alors quels sont les livres de la
semaine je vais dire qui rit je suis
écoeuré à bord je suis l union que des
livres comme ceux dont je vais te parler
paraissent en france c'est un acte
d'insubordination et d'incivilités total
voilà le premier bouquin de service
apple n'a 110 moyens les groupes
arnaquer l'état ouais c'est dire que ça
t'apprend en long et en large
cet ancien comment le pape et des impôts
à les éviter en toute légalité
comment prendre un train gratuitement
comment pas mettre de timbres sur ton
enveloppe pour des tas de gens comment
préféré le concubinage de mariage tir
était marié toit
oui tu as deux enfants fouet et ben je
vais dire divorce parce que si tu n'es
vors et tu vis en concubinage à t'en
avec ta femme tu paye beaucoup moins
d'impôts ah bon absolument
absolument alors tu peux parler à
l'église la synagogue ou une mosquée si
tu as envie mais le concubinage c'est
beaucoup mieux parmi eux pas payer tu as
envie d'être en première
très simple tu prends un train où tu vas
quelque part c'est la seconde est plein
il n'y a pas de siège à si la loi oblige
à donner la sncf a donné un siège à
sinon tu vas t'asseoir première et 6e le
type qui viennent au sauveur dit mais
attendez vous avez pas une classe
première vous avec la seconde 10 mai
monsieur la seconde est plein et silvère
efficaces au monde fn il peut rien faire
et n'a pas le droit de demander un
supplément
et ça c'est vrai pour tous car c'est un
mec qui journaliste qui a relu tous le
code général des impôts qu'elle eut
toutes les lois et quand une idée noire
évidemment il faut du temps il va mettre
au chômage tous les conseils fiscaux
tous les conseils à loin pourquoi parce
que effectivement tu peux échapper à
beaucoup beaucoup de choses
par exemple j'ai lu le londres de gens
réalisent des gens il la donne à qui tu
peux envoyer des lettres sans mettre à
table et ben je vais dire il ya à peu
près 400 associations instituts et
autres
la solution à laquelle tu n'as pas
besoin d'envoyer une lettre avec un
théâtre ouais alors vraiment j'ai honte
j'ai rongé dire tu vois par exemple on
te dit divorcer on te dit aussi par
exemple c'est extraordinaire contrôleurs
j'ai dans le train il vient de demander
ton billet tu lui dis mais monsieur je
suis pas tenus de montrer mon billet
aller mais comment vous êtes tenus et
bien vous n'avez pas vos gants blancs au
sur vos gants blancs car selon la loi le
contrôleur sncf doit avoir des gants
blancs quand bien que voir et s'il n'a
pas ses gants blancs et battu peut lui
refuser tout à fait légalement de
montrer ton billet il ya eu
jurisprudence les fameux courrier du cio
anthony vous avez gagné cinq cent mille
francs
madame michu et tubes qui ont fait le
marathon truqués puis tu vois que vous
avez gagné cinq cent mille francs
si vous participez au loto etc hors la
loi de 11 août 1990 punit la publicité
mensongère
il ya une dame de lyon qui a reçu c'est
l'animateur dé j'ai gagné cinq cent
mille francs pour payer moi vous me dis
que j'ai gagné 500 livres elle a suivi
cinq cent mille francs par juste -
jurisprudence donc quand vous recevez
dans votre courrier cette espèce de truc
que tu vas monter n'annonce n'importe
quoi
eh bien tu peux attaquer c'est un livre
révolutionnaire
je vais te dire je demande la mise en
prison et l'interdiction de ce livre
parce que mucha si l'état ne peut plus
nous arnaquer et si c'est nous qui nous
en a qui me tasser très grand deuxième
libre de ce genre lettre ouverte aux
français qui s'usent en travaillant et
livré mieux le s'enrichir en dormant
alors il explique que pour les tas de
gens quand vous avez une petite maison
quand vous avez un petit patrimoine
au lieu de vous emmerder à chercher du
travail à votre hymne et du matin au
soir
vous le mettez en sicav à l'assurance
vie des tas d'opérations d'ailleurs
depuis la gauche tous et jamais la
bourse a aussi bien marché etc
eh bien tu mets ça dans un certain
nombre de processus financiers et de
manipulations financières et tu gagne
pratiquement autant d'argent que si tu
bosses et donc ça change tout ça ouvre
des perspectives formidables et ça c'est
un signe de société que de bouquets
apparaissent en même temps qu'ils
marchent d'ailleurs qui commence à
marcher très fort on peut dire qu'il
vaut mieux dormait comme ça tu dis
et bien moi je vais te dire ça nous
plonge dans un internat sans fin et
thierry si tu perds mais je vais aller
marichy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir merci d'avoir passé cette soirée
avec nous au bar de la plage prochaine
ouverture samedi prochain salut bande de
nantes
une foire
maliki
[Musique]
omaha
p
[Musique]
oui
poule à
tous
[Musique]
mikko
ban
[Musique]
m
à
yao
ça vaut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en plus des faits
quand je suis
de la plage la question était quel est
le surnom de richard 2 août du groupe
il était une fois et la réponse ripon
[Musique]
vous avez gagné 1,5 machine philips
comportant un lecteur cd une double
platine k7 et un tuner bravo
antenne 2 et philips vous en présenter
le bar de la plage l'émission d'été 2-1
à dix ans et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus